et vu parce qu'on voit pas très bien
quand elle passe elle a un look est
totalement transparent quand tu vas te
faire juger effectivement pour ça
s'appelle l'amour est ce que vous
trouvez que ça va pas trop la ramener
mais je montre aux serbes
et bah qu'est ce que l'on sait vous
voyez je suis venu sans les sens ça n'a
peut-être pas de procès mais elle a
peut-être un procès mais elle peut
connaître le barreau de paris au niveau
de palma ya deux choses d'abord la pause
déjeuner son avocat lui a demandé
d'effacer tous ces tweets ce qu'elle a
fait parce qu'elle s'est rendu compte de
son erreur et après c'est nabila et
nabila sa fin vous votre langue première
c'est le français
nabila sa langue première c'est le
recruteur ruiz et internet c'est machin
c'est seule façon de section alors c'est
peut-être effectivement une erreur c'est
peut-être totalement puéril c'est
peut-être complètement à côté de la 2d
en l'occurrence ce sont ces s'arrête dur
secondes sur votre phrase bravo benhaim
alors vraiment
pour savoir ses sorties de votre bouche
comme ça où c'était prépare avant non
faisais mes voitures à jour et vous pour
vous votre langue c'est le français
qu'on à bidasse et twitter ses feuilles
se posa mais naïve